حيث استهدفنا واخرجنا عن الخدمه خلال 100
يوم بفضل الله
وعونه نحو الف اليه عسكريه
صهيونيه اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه
اخبار الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد 100 يوم على
حرب غزه ابو عبيده يقول ان الاحتلال اخفق
في تحقيق اهدافه بما فيها تحرير الاسر
ويكشف ان مصير العديد منهم اضحى مجهولا
ويرجح مقتلهم بسبب الق
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول انه يواصل سعيه
لتصفيه قاده حماس وان تقديراته تشير الى
ان معظمهم لا يزالون احيا تجدون المزيد من
اخبار حرب غزه في رابط التعليق الاول
احتجاجا على قانون الهجره الجديد عشرات
الالاف يتظاهرون في فرنسا ضد قانون يسمح
للسلطات بترحيل الافراد الذين تقل اعمارهم
عن 13 عاما عند وصولهم الى البلاد وسط
انتقادات للقانون بانه يتبنى الكثير من
افكار اليمين المتطرف خلال اجتماع لمستشار
الامن القومي من دول عده في دافوس
اوكرانيا تطرح صيغه سلام لانهاء الحرب
الدائره منذ ما يقرب من عامين مع روسيا
سويسرا التي تستضيف المنتدى تقول ان
محادثات السلام الاوكرانيه تهدف الى وضع
لمسات نهائيه على مبادئ من اجل سلام عادل
ودائم في اوكرانيا حسب وصفها منظمه
اوكسفام الخيريه تقول في تقرير عدم
المساوى السنوي ان اغنى خمسه رجال في
العالم ضاعفوا صافي ثرواتهم منذ عام
2022 بنسبه
114% لتبلغ ثرواتهم مجتمعه اكثر من
860 مليار دولار الى
اللقاء y